Since the industrial revolution, humans have released over 1.5 trillion,
tons of carbon dioxide or CO2 into the Earth's atmosphere.
In the year 2019,
we were still pumping out around 37 billion more that's
50% more than the year,
2000 and almost three times as much as 50 years ago.
And it's not just CO2.
We're also pumping out growing volumes of other greenhouse gases,
such as methane and nitrous oxide combining all of our greenhouse
gases, where a meeting at 51 billion,
tons of carbon dioxide equivalents each year and emissions
keep rising, but they need to get down to zero.
In recent years,
the consequences have become more serious and visible almost every year breaks
some horrible record. We've had more heat waves,
the most classiest melting and the lowest amount of ice ever recorded at the
North pole of the last 22 years,
20 have been the hottest on record.
The only way to limit this rapid climate change is to decrease our collective
emissions quickly.
But although all countries agree on this goal in principle,
they do not agree who is responsible or who should bear the heaviest load.
The developed countries pointed their own efforts to reduce emissions.
And the fact that the large developing countries on the rise,
especially China are currently releasing much more CO2.
On the other hand, developing countries argue that emissions by the West,
our lifestyle emissions, while for developing countries,
they are survival emissions. Others called rich countries,
hypocrites that got rich by polluting without restraint,
and now expect others not to industrialize and stay fall.
So who is responsible for climate change and CO2 emissions.
And regardless of the past,
who leads to do the most today in this video,
we'll talk exclusively about nation States.
We'll look at the fossil fuel industry in another video question,
one of three,
which countries emit the most carbon dioxide today in
2017, humans emitted about 36 billion, tons of CO2,
more than 50% came from Asia,
North America and Europe followed with 18% and 17%
while Africa,
South America and Oceania together only contributed 8%.
China is by far the world's largest emitter with 10 billion,
tons of CO2 every year or 27% of global emissions.
It's followed by the USA with 15% and the European union with around 10%
together. This is more than half of the world's CO2 emissions.
It's clear that without the willingness and action of these three industrial
blocks,
humanity will not be able to become carbon neutral and prevent severe climate
change.
Next on our list is India at 7% Russia at 5%
Japan at 3% and Iran, Saudi Arabia,
South Korea and Canada, or just short of 2%
together with the first three,
the top 10 are responsible for 75% of global emissions.
But if we only look at the current situation,
we're not getting the full picture question two of three,
which countries have admitted the most in total.
If we look at emissions throughout history, until today,
the outlook changes drastically the us and the EU
both knocked China off the top spot.
The U S is responsible for 25% of the world's historical emissions,
amazing 400 billion tons, mostly in the 20th century.
And second place is the EU that 22% China comes in
third that just under 13% around half of the USA's
contribution,
India's contribution shrinks to 3% along with the whole of Africa and South
America.
The UK is responsible for 1% of annual global emissions,
but takes 5% of the historical response. [inaudible]
Germany producing 2% of emissions per year.
Today has contributed almost 6% as much as the whole of Africa and
South America combined.
So the narrative that rapid climate change is really the responsibility of the
developing world is hard to defend facts matter,
but this is still not the whole story because focusing on countries mixes,
two things, population numbers, and total emissions.
If a country has more people in general,
it's emissions are of course higher things look very different.
If we look at the jewels like you,
dear viewer question three of three countries emit
the most carbon dioxide per person.
The average human is responsible for around five tons of CO2 each year,
but averages can be misleading.
The countries with the largest CO2 emissions per person are some of the world's
major Auden gas producers and 2017.
Qatar had the highest emissions at a hefty 49 tons per person
followed by Trinidad and Tobago, Kuwait, the United Arab Emirates,
Brunei Bahrain, and Saudi Arabia.
But those are outliers Australia. Yeah.
Have one of the highest carbon footprint per person, 17 tons a year.
That's more than triple the global average and slightly more than the average us
American and Canadian at 16 tons.
The Germans do a little better at close to 10 tons, but this is still twice.
The global average China may be the world's largest to matter,
but it's also the world's most populous country with over 1.4 billion people,
18.5% of the world population per person.
It's above average at seven tons.
Historically CO2 emissions have been closely tied to a high standard of living.
Wealth is one of the strongest indicators of our carbon footprint because as we
move from Porter rich, we gain access to electricity,
heating air conditioning, lighting, modern cooking, causal planes,
smartphones, computers, and interact with people across the world. Online.
The enormous rise of China's CO2 emissions is coupled with the greatest
reduction of poverty in history.
If we order CO2 emissions by income,
we see that the richest half of countries are responsible for 86% of global
emissions and the bottom half for only 14%,
the average German emits more than five times,
as much as the average Indian in just 2.3 days,
the average American emits as much as the average Nigerian in a year.
And not only that,
the harsh reality is that it's the countries that contribute least to the
problem that stand to lose the most from rapid climate change,
the developing world will be hit.
The hardest the consequences could be food insecurity,
conflicts over resources,
harsher and more frequent natural disasters and large climate refugee movement.
Question four of three.
So who should take responsibility?
Many of today's richest countries are in a convenient position.
They have become rich over centuries of fossil fuel burning and industrial
production.
They have a large historical footprint and their wealth means they still are met
a lot per person,
but that country's annual emissions are now dwarfed by other countries because
the giant that is China is finally catching up and other giants like India are
on their way. Many Germans. For example, wonder how,
if Germany only accounts for 2% of yearly emissions,
it can have a meaningful impact on reducing emissions.
The answer is simple for one, the richest countries have the resources,
highly educated workforces and technology to develop low cost,
low carbon solutions and spread them around the world.
If we don't want poorer countries to become as fossil fuel dependent as we are,
we need low carbon technology to be cheap and available.
And we're getting there.
The cost of renewables is falling quickly and the variety of solutions are on
the horizon for many different sectors,
but it needs to happen much faster.
If the rich countries of the West to scientists seriously tackle rapid climate
change, the rest of the world would follow because it has no choice.
Just like when the European union enforced energy efficiency standards for
technology. The rest of the world adopted them too,
because they wanted to be able to continue trading with the blog. Still.
This doesn't absolve others of their responsibility.
China is the largest CO2 emitter today,
and it's China's responsibility to grow in a way that will make it possible to
transition to a zero carbon world in time.
Others acting irresponsibly yesterday is a horrible excuse for
repeating the same mistakes today.
Climate change is a global problem and no country alone can fix it.
Working out who's responsible is not as simple as it seems.
And in a way it's a daft question,
but one that has played international politics for decades in the end,
it's pretty simple. Everybody needs to do the best they can.
And right now we are all not doing that,
but we can begin today.
This video is part of a series about climate change.
It's supported by a breakthrough energy, a coalition founded by bill Gates.
That's working to expand the clean energy investment and support the innovations
that will lead the world to net zero carbon emissions.
Also a special thanks to the team at our world in data for helping us out with
data and research.
[Inaudible].